right good evening members and officers
of the council no members of the public
good and welcome to the meeting of the
standards committee usual housekeeping
rules if the fire alarm is activated
please vacate the offices V the stairs
either through the security door to the
to the right of me or behind me please
don't do not use the lifts and assemble
in the Holy Square on the green and
officers will assist you and advise you
when it's deam safe to return does
anybody intend to film the
meeting no good no members of the public
here we can skip that police notation
meeting is being live streamed for
members of the public except for any
item of business where exempt or
confidential information is considered
following the exclusion of the press and
the public from the meeting the meeting
is also being recorded will be broadcast
on the council's YouTube could everybody
please ensure their mobile phones are
turned off and they're not used to make
calls in the chamber while this meeting
is in
progress and does any member wish to
speak under Council rule procedure
20.1 there good before we go into item
item agenda item one I'd like to
introduce the new monitoring officer uh
ingred Brown and say welcome to you to
your our first standards committee
meeting
thank you very much chair I'm really
happy to be here really happy to be in
thanet um and look forward to working
with you all just by way a bit of
background um I'm in week four of my
post here so just still really getting
to know people and um prior to that I
was Deputy monitoring officer and head
of legal uh BCP a big unitary Authority
so yeah really happy to be here and I've
been made very welcome and as I said um
really look forward to working with you
all on standards I'm passion about
standards and and sat on standards
committee for all the time that I was on
BCP so or was the legal advisor to be to
standards so sorry Bournemouth
Bournemouth Christ Church and Paul thank
you thank you
everybody thank you INRI right agenda
item one any apologies for absence we've
received one from Michael Clark are
there any
others okay minutes of the previous
meeting I move that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 10th of November
2022 two be approved and signed as a
correct record could I have a seconder
please Council Kinton unless anyone's
got any objections to the minutes I'll
will take them as
agreed thank you are there any
Declarations of Interest no good I'll
now invite Mr use to open comments on
agenda item
four thank you chairman um so uh this
report is um looking at our uh key
decision thresholds so as part of the
review of The Independent monitoring
officer uh it was recommended as it says
at 1.1 to review the scheme of
delegations to ensure that it's clear
clear and easy to understand and
includes appropriate conditions bless
you um thereby defining sorry uh
includes approprate conditions requiring
engagement of counselors in strategic
and IR decisions so what we're doing is
um we had a a report went to uh general
purposes um and that set what the
officer scheme of delegations was so
this is doing the other end of the um
delegation system so we are deciding
what uh level at which we want to set uh
the decision-making thresholds so that
councilors in this case cabinet uh can
look at the Strategic and high-risk
decisions so we've got a current uh
definition of our um key decision or
what the council considers to be a key
decision which is outlined of paragraph
2.1 um we've then looked at uh the main
the main one is is effectively anything
over uh 250,000 pound spend uh
expenditure essentially um we've looked
at uh the other councils in Kent uh and
uh you can see that uh four others set
their Threshold at £250,000 uh one is
AT3 300 um one is at 50 which is like
wow um and then others have got um the
Fantastic word of
significant whatever that means um so by
having a specific amount of money there
are no ambiguities about what the
definition of significant would be
because obviously everybody's um
definition of that is is slightly
different so um looking at the uh
paragraph 2.3 uh We've made some changes
in red you can highlight
those so uh where what we've done is um
include a bit where it
says um where the approval has
previously been received to incur
expenditure and also the acquisition
enhancement and disposal of land with a
value of over a million
pounds and then we've also got two uh
which is uh where we have a contract uh
rather than a purchase or a disposal of
something uh over £250,000 these are
where the council engages into a long uh
contract over a period of years and the
lifetime value of that contract is over
£750,000 so to sort of give a bit more
clarity we've included some examples in
paragraph 4 so I'll just go through
those so uh example number one uh
Council wishes to buy some new Refuge
Vehicles cost 3.2 million pounds is that
more than 250 yes it is clearly it's a
key decision nice simple straightforward
one example two councell enters into a
four-year contract uh for a computer
system it's four it's £ 105,000 per year
um and it's four years so that total
cost would be £420,000
that's less than £750 so not a key
decision um that's again hopefully
pretty straight forward uh and then
example three so we create a land trust
we put £5 million in to buy up
interesting properties around thanet and
and do them up uh for the benefit of
thanet so that setting up of that land
trust and putting the five million in
the in the budget that's your key
decision because you're spending over
£250,000
now um when you're going and spending
that5 million p on properties in thanet
um say for example somebody purchased a
property of 650,000 which is not unheard
of these days um that wouldn't be a key
decision because looking at 1A we've
already got permission to spend that
money there was already a key decision
to spend that money okay however if one
of those properties that he wanted to
buy was one and a half million pounds
that would be another key decision
because the council thinks that it's
inappropriate for a single officer to
spend a million pounds which is a a huge
amount of money um and to be honest I
think quite a lot of officers wouldn't
be comfortable in spending that amount
of money on their own so um essentially
what we're saying there is if you've got
to if you're spending if you're spending
a big amount of money but then dividing
it up if those smaller amounts are less
than a million pounds then they're not
key decisions but if any of one of those
indiv idual ones is above a million
pounds that's so significant that needs
to be a key decision in its own right
okay um so constitutional uh review
working party looked at this uh a couple
of weeks ago um and they've recommended
um as per 2.3 so that's the paragraph
with the red colors in um they didn't
suggest any
changes um that's pretty much it really
we're looking for a recommendation on to
full Council uh on December for December
the 7th meeting um so if anyone's got
any questions I'm happy to answer them
councilor
criton thank you um I'll start with the
easy little bit there's a little I
didn't read this with a fine tooth comb
but one typo did sort of leap off the
page at me in 2.3.1 there should be no s
on the end of involve that's me being
the proof reader coming out of me um but
I did have some questions um genuine
questions to follow from that um I was
wanted to know a bit more about the
desktop research and the um how you came
to the conclusions so you looked at it
and you decided that
250,000 was the figure that you wanted
to set was that the figure it was
already at and then in that case
um looking at the other authorities that
you looked at when did they last set
their Figures were so the 300,000 was
that like set last year but the 50,000
was set 10 years ago how do they and
also how do they compare to those
authorities budgets compared to ours so
if our budget is worth twice the one
that's has a limit of 300 was that taken
into account um
and because I just feel that 300,000 in
today's market is actually sorry 250,000
in today's market is actually touching
on the low side um I wouldn't want to
see it much higher but I would have
thought that 300 300 just kind of seems
better so I just wondered why you you
left at 250 based and where all of that
other that desktop research all tied in
in a bit more
detail so um it was originally £250,000
um we weren't actively looking to change
it uh we wanted to compare ourselves uh
due to the IMO recommendation um we
wanted to review to see where we were
against other people um so looking at
the other councils in Kent
250 was the most popular one um it's
difficult to tell with people's
constitutions um as to when they were
last reviewed um because although they
have a date that says last reviewed on
the front normally that's not
necessarily the bit of the Constitution
that you're particularly looking at um
the with regards to budgets these are
all district councils that we haven't
included Kent we haven't included meway
uh in the list um so with regards to
that that they are all pretty much of a
similar budget I wouldn't say they're
they're not wildly different from from a
local District Council budget within
Kent
um yeah we've taken this through cabinet
cabinet were happy with a 250,000 limit
um we felt that as and and corporate
management team felt that the quarter a
million was a a fair amount that could
get quite a lot done by officers but
receiving or retaining the ability for
members to to take the the the sort of
the most important decisions is that
helpful what I missed a bit
out um I'm coming back with a slight an
additional question really is um when do
you envisage reviewing the £250,000 next
if it's going to stay at that this
time um I'm I'm quite happy to put a a a
placeholder for a review in the future
it's not something that we've actively
talked about with with cabinet or with
CMT but I'm happy to look in I would
say certainly no less than 18 months
time um because as I say these don't
change all that often if I'm being
honest um but yeah I mean I'm I'm happy
to put an 18-month 2-year review in to
to come back and and look at it again
and do another desktop
exercise so may I in that case um option
two which was the cwrp
recommendation um if we approve that but
could add if obviously if others agree
plus a review and I did say next year on
my notes here but in two years time um
uh of the financial definition currently
set at
250,000 um because 250,000 is the price
of a Terrace house it's I know it sounds
like a lot of money but at the same time
in the current climate um it's becoming
increasingly less that's not a strange
phrase but yeah thank
you councelor christon can I just add I
suppose the other thing um with um key
decisions is is the principle of
transparency and obviously the you know
spending public money making sure it's
on the forward plan so there's an a
heightened element of scrutiny it's not
just about decision- making and kind of
um you know thwarting officers
decision-making Powers but it's really
about that level of transparency that's
felt you know appropriate at that
level
C um just to say yes thank you um for
that I also understand that even if an
officer wanted to spend less than the
250,000 like it was
249 they could actually request it to be
put forward as a key decision anyway so
if they if they felt that there was the
concern so by putting a little bit on it
it wouldn't necessarily remove that
Safeguard although it does require us to
have obviously that trust with officers
I appreciate that but thank you for 10
yeah know that that that's exactly the
case and of course there's the other
part of the criteria which is
significant in two or more Wards and
that that's the other thing that needs
to be
considered thank you Council
bayford thank you uh chair not a
question just to say I really welcome
the clarification um and I think that
I'm I'm happy with with the figures but
I think the examples uh very very
helpful and useful in understanding the
small es well thank
you I think safe to say as well that
this figure has not been queried by
cabinet or by the Constitutional review
working party and everybody was happy
with that values yes but don't worry
about that that's what you're here
for does anybody else got any comments
to
make in that case could I please
have a propos on a second that we that
the record is recommended to full
Council proposed by Council
bayford I sorry can I just say I I
suggested that it was item two which was
the cwrp recommendation plus a review in
two years of the actual definition
currently set at 250 so you you want
could
you so you want us to write in the RW
period rather than send it
back for revision an
amendment okay can can can somebody can
yeah yeah I think so yeah can somebody
make a proposal then with that wording
which what your wording is
please in that case I'd like to propose
um option to uh cwrp recommendation plus
a review of the financial definition
currently set at 250,00
000 within two years of this
meeting in that case can I have a
proposal for that councilor bayford is
there a second up councilor endom thank
you all agreed thank you very
much can I ask Mr yen to now comment on
item agenda five the policy
framework uh thank you chairman uh the
so I won't go over the same reasons why
we're doing it it's about the M uh about
the um independent monitoring officer
same as the uh previous one this is the
this is the other half of what we like
to say are the uh engagement of
councilors in strategic and high-risk
decisions so every Council across the
land has a uh what's called a policy
framework and that is a set of policies
that the council uh considers so
important that all councilors are um
allowed to have a vote on them at a full
council meeting so some of those things
um are things that by law have to be
um uh taken and decided upon by Council
things like local plan for example um
but also you have what's called local
Choice functions um and for those of you
who have been here a long time uh will
have noticed me saying that uh cabinet
can only look at cabinet things Council
can only look at Council things uh well
this is the exception to the rule so if
somebody if the council as a corporate
body feels it's something is so
important that uh all Council should
have u a view on it they would uh we
would include uh that item uh on the
council's policy framework so you can
see what the current policy framework is
at
2.3 uh and the
amended and suggested um changes to uh
the policy framework are outlined at 2.4
so we will be removing local transport
plan uh the housing investment program
and the food law enforcement service
plan um and replacing those um with uh
mainly the housing homelessness and
rough sleeping strategy the housing
assistance policy and the HRA business
plan um so um the local transport plan
uh is a policy that forms uh part of the
highways information for the council's
local plan
um uh that uh as it's part of the
council's local plan is covered by point
two which is all the plans and
strategies that together comprise the
local plan so by definition it's in
there twice so we've hked that out we
don't need that anymore uh because
that's covered under point two uh and we
think that's probably a hangover from
when uh thanet was the highways
Authority which gives an indication of
how long it is since this was uh
previously reviewed um and the um
housing investment program uh after
speaking to the housing team is not
again something that really exists it
doesn't really mean anything uh from a
housing point of view so it's much more
um uh clear and transparent to include
those three policies there at four five
and six which are like the really key
significant housing policies that uh
that that the housing team feel as if
councils as councilors should all have a
a say in and the food law enforcement
service plan is again it's it's it's
still required but it's not required to
be part of our council's framework I
think when it was originally created
there was a need for that to be part of
it um now it's still a council thing um
but um generally it's it's
um something that that's unnecessary to
be included in the in the forward plan
because it sorry in the policy framework
because when we say is it one of the
council's most important things no no it
isn't let's be honest it's it is
important in its own way but it's not
amongst the most important things the
council
does um what's also uh important to note
a couple of other things is uh this has
been through our corporate management
team and it's also been through cabinet
so they're both happy with this um and
this is not an exhaustive list so if
there are other things like the budget
for example budget by law has to come to
um full Council those things are are
things that are are separately important
but they don't need to be part of our
policy framework um so we did have a a
bit of a a quick look around um some of
the other councils in
Kent um generally it's it's pretty
similar really um there's no major issue
isues um some councils in Kent folkton
and I think 7even Oaks I think are the
two um have decided to include
everything that goes to council so when
I said there were other things that
Council by law have to do they decided
to include all of those things in their
policy framework so it runs to like a
side and a half of A4 which it's bit
unnecessary really I think um not don't
tell their them Services teams I said
that but um uh yeah it should really be
focused on the things that are the most
important things to the council um the
very last thing that I'd like to say is
that what you do need to bear in mind is
if that you do wish to recommend
something becomes part of our policy
framework if it's a cabinet function and
what I call local choice if you take
that out and put it into the policy
framework it becomes a council function
so if you've got like a a cabinet
Advisory Group for example on a
particular issue and if you wanted to
put that into the policy framework it
wouldn't be able to be a CAG anymore
because there wouldn't be that cabinet
scrutiny because it's a council function
if that makes sense um but other than
that happy to take any
questions councilor Austin I just wanted
to point out that at at the previous
discussion about this I had suggested
that climate change be slotted in and
you explained Nick that that that
actually wouldn't work in our favor as
it were because it would it would mean
that the process would be different and
and I understood that and and I get that
now thank you Council cron much much
shorter and simpler this one um the
current food law enforcement service
plan when I tried to look at it appeared
to uh be out of date it was expired on
20 in 2020 April um it might be that I
just didn't find a current one and I
found an old one on the system so um I
was just wondering if you could clarify
that and say when it will be updated
because as you you said it is important
even if it doesn't need to be on here um
and I can I just clarify if it's not on
here where does it go I I know that
might sound like a stupid question but
um what happens to it where does it hang
instead What specifically the food law
safety plan um it's it's it sits in that
sort of pot of things that have to go to
council so it's still a um it's it's a
council function uh and it sits with um
Penny buttons team the enforcement safe
neighborhoods uh people
um yeah I don't actually know off the
top of my head um it may be that you
can't find it cuz I know the last couple
have been on pink papers so that might
be the reason why because essentially is
the food safety plan it's about telling
the council how we're going to inspect
properties uh not properties sorry
venues and and premises and you don't
want to tell people how to how we're
going to go about doing the um the the
searches and stuff in in public forum so
that may be the reason but I certainly
get can we make a note of that and we'll
certainly
get oh absolutely yeah yeah yeah just to
reflect that yeah definitely yeah thank
you are there any any other
comments okay in that case could I
please have a proposal in a second for
the recommendation that members are
asked to re to consider the
recommendation from the Constitutional
review working party make a
recommendation to full Council regarding
the content of the council's policy
framework going have proposer proposed
by Council Austin seconded by Council
bford are we all in favor and agreed
excellent perhaps we can move on to item
agenda six Mr use over to you again
please so uh thank you chair uh this is
uh about tweaking the uh Council
procedure rules specifically about
questions um so uh as it stands at the
moment um theoretically um a member of
the public or a member of council uh
these are interchangeable uh so so for
example remember the public puts a
question into Council and it's put and
it's asked and they get an answer um the
wording is as such in the in the
Constitution that theoretically somebody
could a counselor could put an identical
word for word exactly the same question
in at the next council meeting and that
would be perfectly valid even though
it's been answered in full at the last
council meeting which is a bit weird and
not how the the uh rules were written
they they were written to sort of stop
that from happening so what we've done
is we've tweaked the wording slightly to
make it explicitly clear that if a
question that has been asked by anybody
um cannot then be reput by somebody
within the next six months okay and then
the other thing that we've um also
slightly tweaked again is that um you'll
notice in red uh where it says uh
validly received or put uh because
there's another uh example uh which is a
much more upto-date example of the last
council meeting where um because the
count because the wording says
put theoretically again
you could have one two three counselors
or three members of the public all
putting in the same question but because
none of those three had been put at the
meeting you couldn't you wouldn't be
allowed to reject any of those three
questions so hence why you end up with
three people asking very very similar
questions um so by putting that it means
that um if we've received a question as
soon as the first question is in that is
the thing that then allows us to then
say no to any more questions on exactly
the same subject um it may seem a bit
sort of trivial that we're putting this
in but given the massive increase in
questions that we've had over the last
couple of uh Council meetings we want to
try and make it so that there's enough
time for as many people as possible um
to ask questions and and and to be
honest it's not really in anyone's
interest to have three questions that
are exactly the same or indeed having a
question that was asked at the previous
meeting
word for word or even extremely similar
being asked at the next meeting uh
there's a finite amount of time and we
want to try and maximize the number of
different and varied questions we can
get
through that's it question do anybody
have any comments to make Council
bayford yeah just say I totally agree I
think it's very important that that this
this is put in because you know the time
is limited and it's only fair that
people should have a chance to ask a
question it it's totally um inefficient
for it to be repeated so I I'm fully in
favor of this thank you Council critton
yes I I also um it it does make complete
sense um the only thing I I wanted to
ask was um sometimes as they say things
in politics can move quite fast and
certainly whilst it feels like things in
local authorities move slowly sometimes
things suddenly run ahead um I know that
very often our Ward members um are
asking us about things that maybe we did
have answered 3 months ago but
something's changing or whatever and I
felt that six months if you're going to
merge public and counselor questions I
felt that 6 months seemed like a little
bit of a long time and would have
preferred something like 4 months and I
didn't know whether or not that could be
considered or if anyone else thought the
same does anybody else wish to say what
council CR has just commented on
I personally don't agree because two
months meetings AR sorry we have
meetings every a couple of months yes
quite we do only have meetings every
couple of months and um surely a member
of public can receive an explanation of
of the re the reason why I think six
months is
fine we I think without commenting on
the merits of four or six months I think
if something changed then I think that
would be significantly different enough
if you said okay well uh yeah this
question was asked at the last meeting
but actually there's been a material
change in what's happened the house in
question's been demolished or something
like that then I think that would allow
for that sort of supplementary and
inverted commas
question anybody else got any
observations councilor Austin yeah just
wanting to pick up on that that we did
have a discussion about it didn't we at
the Constitution review working party
and I was I was asking about what
happens if a member says no what I'm
asking is different from and and you
explained what the process would be and
who who would look at that and so on um
yes so just just to to to reiterate that
so it's um yeah so we as Dem Services
officers uh do a first check of the
question so we make sure it's within the
word limit make sure it's addressed to a
Cabinet member sort of the basic things
that are clearly if they don't follow
that process it's clearly it's a no um
and we write back to the the the
question which I'm sure some of you will
have noted in the past and said terribly
sorry too many qu too many words or it's
you haven't said who it's to um if they
pass all those tests then we pass it on
to um monitoring officer uh Ingrid and
then she'll look at it and say yeah I
think that's that's okay no problems we
say back thanks very much all good on
the list
if we feel that it's not or it's quite
similar or there's a reason why we might
want to reject that then those go to the
chief executive because in the in the
Constitution the person who rejects
theoretically Rejects and approves
questions is is the chief executive um
he will look at it and say yes I think
that is acceptable keep it in or
actually yeah you know what I don't
think this is this is too similar to one
that's
that's asked before or it's uh more
often than not it it verges on the
frivolous or um defamatory type sort of
threshold um but even then even if he
does want to um uh reject that question
he still has to talk to the chairman of
council to have a conversation with him
to say I'm going to reject this and at
that point the council the council
chairman has the point of uh has has the
chance to put a a counselor's point of
view into that thought process that that
the chief is's having so there's there's
a lot of of steps in that process that
that are designed to to allow as many
questions as possible we're not we're
not here there to try and those all
those stages are not there to sort of be
multiple cves to make sure that stuff
gets thrown out it's it's the opposite
way
around um just thinking about what
you've been saying saying um I'm
thinking back to um the meeting where we
had I think probably at least half a
dozen questions on manston some of them
were quite similar some of them were
were slightly different a couple were
from members of the public um and
several were from obviously members of
of the council um within what you do is
there any way in which you can composite
some of those several questions or would
you have to I mean if they if they're
subtly different would you still let
them through or is there any way you
could bring them together I'm
particularly thinking that that members
of the public don't want you know
they're the ones I I really wouldn't
want to leave them out because that's
they're the ones we're here for um and
yeah thank
you comp compositing questions is not
something that I would ever want to do
as an officer because as soon as you do
that and you start taking bits and
pieces out of other people's questions
people tend to get quite irked by that
um and also because they want the
opportunity to ask the question
themselves that's the other thing that
we've we've found where if you say well
I'm terribly sorry you can't ask yours
because it's a bit similar that's just a
red rag to a bull uh if we're being
honest um it's a nice idea but I think
the practicalities of actually doing it
are extremely challenging for officers
because again if members if you did that
with
members that's then sort of stepping on
members toes and saying well actually
I'm not letting you talk to this bit and
I'm going to take that bit out of the
question and actually that might be the
really killer political thing that you
wanted to hang your supplementary
question and then again you get into if
you've composited two questions together
who gets the supplementary question you
have two supplementary questions it's
it's yeah that doesn't want to come
across as it's really hard so we're not
doing it but but I think there are
significant challenges to doing
that I think it's safe to say that if a
question from especially a member of the
public is rejected along these
recommendations then I'm sure the
response from democratic services will
explain it fully so that the member of
the public will understand am I right Mr
use uh yes yes we can we will as as well
moving forwards we will be more specific
in the reasons why we've rejected stuff
um we can't suggest ways to make things
valid if that makes sense but we can
tell people why why something isn't
valid um but I think I'll make the same
point I did last time which is that if
people put their questions in now for
the December council meeting we've got
plenty of time to do that if they leave
it to like half an hour before the
deadline which is often the case then
even with the best will in the world
it's quite a challenge for us to be able
to give detailed advice on that shorter
time scale councelor Austin did you I
just wanted to pick up we had the same
discussion didn't we or a similar
discussion at constitutional review
working party because I was saying well
couldn't you just say councelor x you
might want to talk to councelor Y who
was already done but Nick said he felt
that would be treading on the toes of
members responsibilities and not an
appropriate thing for an officer to be
doing and and I get
that Council Kint are you wishing to
make a proposal to amend the
recommendation I don't I don't want to
make a any recommendation to amend it
but I I just felt it would be useful to
to just have a discussion on those
things obviously I'm not in cwrp so um
it's just those were the things that
concerned me and you know we did have
that rather bizarre situation where we
had sort of like about six or whatever
it was questions on one subject and they
were all subtly different um but the
answers got very repetitive because
that's the way it was so we just have to
carry on and work it out as best we can
but thank you thank you for for your
answers thank you I think what I can do
can I read out the recommendations first
before we ask for a second R proposer
the recommendations are to amend part
four rules of procedure paragraph 13.5
of the council's Constitution to read
the chief executive will reject a
question if it is substantially the same
as a question which has been validly
received or put at a meeting of the
council in the s past 6 months by either
a counselor or a member of the public to
amend part four rules of procedure
paragraph 14.6 of the council's
Constitution to read a question will not
be substantially the same as a question
which has been violently received or put
at a meeting of the council in the past
six months by either a counselor or a
member of the public could I have a
propos for the recommendations
please
statistics of the current complaints
does anybody want to raise any comments
about them Council cron only just to say
that the very last item says no further
action but it's still open
yes I think that's cuz the letters
haven't been written I think is that
yeah so yes so so the
um the subcommittee the standard
assessment subcommittee has met it's
decided that it's no further action but
we're still in the process of sending
all of the paperwork out so slightly
oddly it is no further action and still
open at the same time but will'll be
closed very
soon I think I think I think so have
probably all the letters are just out
done but post the report being concluded
and you've got the change you got the
change over between the two monitoring
officers and I know Gabrielle has not
been well so that could also be another
valid reason for the
delay counc
bayford I I've noticed that um when
there is a complaint got counselor and
there is no further action it can take a
very long time for that counselor to be
told that's the case which I think is
unfortunate because it can be quite
worrying Mr use would you like to
comment or ingred
well really just to note that's the case
and I think my commitment is certainly
to to process those complaints as
speedily as possible but obviously
sometimes evidence needs to be gathered
and the councelor needs a chance to
respond so there is there is a process
to go through and sometimes
unfortunately that can be time you know
that can take more time than one would
hope but certainly totally recognize
that that can be a really stressful
process and obviously councilors it's
open to counselors to contact the
independent monitoring independent
person sorry for for support and um but
I I I I recognize what you're saying and
I think it's really important that in so
far as we can process as speedily as
possible that we we commit to that thank
you yeah I do think that's important
because I I know that um I I thought
that once something had come to
standards and and no further action was
recommended it would be immediate that
that counselor was
informed I mean I totally take that on
board um I don't in in this recent
complaint I can't comment except to say
that obviously there has been a change
in monitoring officer but my
understanding is that all of those
letters are now up to date as of the end
of last week so I suspect that that that
that those kind of were sent out just
after that report was concluded but
totally take on board what you're saying
thank you thanks very much is is it
possible that if no further actions
agreed could a phone call not be made to
the person concerned and explain to them
that formal notice will be followed up
by a letter in due course to save to
take away the
worry chair there's no reason why that
can't happen sometimes it's really
useful to set out if it's a complex
complaint it's really useful to set out
full reasons um obviously but certainly
I think if there's going to be a delay
in the letter that I take that on board
I just a preliminary phone call and then
say the formal letter will be made there
there's no reason why that can't happen
chair thank you counil I just wanted to
ask as a as a new member of of this
committee what did not meet the
jurisdiction test exactly means
please so when a um uh a complaint is
submitted uh by a member of the public
or another counselor uh we do what is or
sorry we don't the monitoring officer
does a What's called the jurisdiction
test so that is a series of questions
that the monitoring officer asks of the
complaint effectively so that is um did
it happen within our time scales if it
didn't doesn't make doesn't make it a
complaint um the other one is if this
matter that had been brought to the
attention was true would it be a breach
of the code if if not then again it just
dies and that is a uh jurisdiction not
met they're the two common most common
ones are they yeah I mean absolutely
Nick thank you but the other one of
course is whether the counselor was
acting in yeah exactly that
yeah and I think that brings the meeting
to a close however there's just one
other question I want to raise which was
raised at the meeting a year ago we
dealt with an assessment where we had a
media policy and it was agreed that the
media that Shamira would look at the
rewriting of the media policy to
differentiate so when people have got
Facebook accounts unfortunately some
counselors are putting counselor Joe
blogs so the public are thinking it's
come from him but when he leaves the his
name off and just puts Joe blogs some
members of the public still think it's
coming from a person who is a counselor
and not just a normal member of Facebook
Tik Tok whatever and I think that all
needs to be clarified I know it needs
some work with as Nick and I were
discussing earlier with Communications
so whether we can look at try to
strengthen that policy because it is a
nasty one happy to pick that up as well
chair and I think it's a really
important thing to get right and it's
something that coun some councilors
really struggle with it's It's Tricky
and also public perception is you know
it's really important to get that right
so I don't know where Samir got to it
got to with it but very happy to pick it
up thank you anybody else got any
comments before we close the meeting in
that case go the meeting closed thank
you all very much for
attending